[Music]
hi nice to meet you Tommy
Thornton good to see and your sales an
event coordinator at the brick room is
how's that you do a lot of events do a
lot of it bad how many a week on average
about 350 a year it sounds like this is
the oxygen that's keeping this place
alive unfortunately that's the truth
Wow what other problems are there help
me staffing is terrible why there's so
many stop answering the door what is
that for and our aspiring them often
I'll come in a Monday and see who didn't
make it through the weekend she's very
tough to work for the bottom line is the
problem is the owner yes there's nobody
else here starts at the top I appreciate
your honesty
we appreciate you being here after
learning the hotels revenue is strictly
from events I want to see how bad the
food really is seasonal local fresh I
ordered a couple of items the French
onion soup which was tasteless bad
terrible so I opted for something with a
little more flavor
that tastes better then I ordered
something I've never heard of before a
cauliflower steak which by name I should
have known better
that is a mess and a crab sandwich which
maybe I would expect to be frozen but
not from a can
product of China commercial mm-hmm
seriously
are we done is right you've got your
burger still you know what
cancel it absolutely cuz if it's coming
from the same kitchen and forget it yeah
tell the chef I travel light not having
got that many [ __ ] pairs of knickers
thank you cancel everything else no more
no more you said enough time into the
kitchen they introduced me to the table
place is huge
kitchen is massive where's the chef
hello I'm not be sure you're not the
chef you are a chef that you got a jack
yard yes that's how chef 10 to dress
makes you I was good to meet you too and
this is very sex marriage so get it
you're the chef I'm not too sure no
you're the chef a chef but not this Asia
there's two there's two of them where's
the head chef well we have both of them
in charge no such thing your set of
rules your set of rules doesn't benefit
the castle's I'll come back to the food
in a minute
I mean shocked before I got here I met a
dozen of your ex employees I couldn't
believe the amount the staff that have
left this building in the last two years
why are you going through so many staff
I don't know you don't know I think I
hire people and so it's them
not good enough for you yes when you
have a young member of staff that is
owed money and they won't leave the
building until you pay them and you call
the police on them what kind of business
are you running here are you saying now
that they're lying
please I don't know why are you saying
they're lying simple yes or no I cannot
tell you you cannot tell it's an
accurate though is an accurate yes I
have witnessed Virender call the cops on
a number of people she has a close
relationship with the Newtown Police
Department did you care about this hotel
it's not funny I mean I am NOT here to
laugh let's get that right let's move on
to my reception when I walked in and
there's dust and [ __ ] everywhere
when I say dust I'm talking dust that's
been embedded for years and there's mold
on the carpet I'm a little bit loss of
words I ever sat down in the restaurant
had dinner right top of your menu it's
fresh
seasonal local is canned foods I'm not a
chef and I don't know all these things
what's wrong you're feeling sick no I
need to take some level oven so you take
it out of the oven
what is this tomorrow's chicken see you
laughs what is this again you have to
[ __ ] wake up